let's talk about uh this this story we
got from cnbc
inflation rose 7.9 percent in february
as food and energy costs push prices to
the highest in more than 40 years every
single month it's good every week same
headlines
same headline they're like the new
numbers have come out and it's worse
than it's been in four decades and i'm
like i feel like i just saw the january
numbers right that was seven and 7.5 and
now it's 7.9 in february so let's talk
about what this means for you guys ian
was just discussing money and currency
and there's some interesting questions
to have here i don't care about the us
dollar in terms of what that means for
you because we got other numbers to deal
with what i care about is
how many hours do you have to work to
eat a meal to to live to have health
care and this is the big problem i have
with the left when they're like 15
minimum wage and i'm like
the number
and the piece of paper or the digital
currency does not change that you will
have to work a set amount of hours to
earn certain resources
if it's it's simple if everyone in the
country is getting paid 15 bucks an hour
to make a widget the cost of widgets
goes up with the cost of labor
so changing the number does not change
the amount of time taken from the person
to produce the object so my my thing is
when it comes to better standards of
living we need it's a supply and demand
issue with labor versus uh
supply demand of demand for labor versus
supply of labor and it's what people are
willing to work for right now people are
not willing to work for that much but
the fact remains
if if it's by government force or by
unionization
if every single person says you know
what the government won't raise our
wages then we're all going to demand it
you will still get inflation and you
will still work the exact same amount of
hours for the exact same resources but
this was the argument
against abolishing slavery
i mean if you well because if you want
really cheap good i mean if you're
saying that well you can't raise wages
because if you raise wages and that's
going to raise the cost of goods
i'm saying that
money represents
time and value time and labor time and
labor won't change by mandate
so what you'll get is there's a few
interesting things the minimum wage will
allow people to buy computers
for for uh for less less time of their
lives so we get our computers made by
you know like sweatshop and slave labor
in a foreign country and if a computer
costs 500
and you get 500 per week from your job
if we give you a 20 raise it'll take you
20 less time to buy that product because
the product is imported from a com from
a country that uses slave labor but if
you're buying american made goods and
their wages go up the same as yours you
now have to pay the same amount of time
for that for their amount of time
right so basically you're saying then
so then what is your solution
to keep wages low
what do you mean for certain groups of
people in order to keep the goods lower
that's not that's not a principle or a
moral position as a fact
it's just it's just a mathematical fact
changing the representation of time and
labor doesn't change time in labor
that's the so if someone comes out and
says but let's put it this way let's use
arbitrary uh gaff tape for every hour
you work you get one gaff tape oh my if
we say well i demand two gaff tape it's
like okay but you still have to work for
for an hour and these items just
represent that hour it doesn't matter
how many of them you have what matters
is what someone is willing to pay in
terms of their time for your time
so
money as a number is
mostly arbitrary it's not entirely and
i'll tell you so i'll tell you when it
comes to inflation what happens is if
you work for one hour and you're given
money to represent that one hour of
labor you can now exchange it for the
equivalent value of one hour someone
else's labor with inflation your time is
being stripped away so now you worked
for an hour and it's the equivalent to a
half an hour that's inflation
the the the the actual number of the
currency this is completely missed by
money on the left and they argue for
minimum wage
if we eliminated currency from the from
the from the from the question
you'd be saying to someone
okay
you work for one hour at my restaurant
and you'll be able to buy a meal
okay
money is irrelevant whether the meal
costs five dollars or ten dollars one
hour gets you one meal
if you tell if if you have two guys and
one guy makes the meal and one guy
sources the food they're both still
going to have to work one hour of their
life to exchange the meal to give the
food to the guy to make the meal so they
could both enjoy it you change their
minimum wage and now 10 represents their
one hour they're still asking for an
hour of each other's time
so
the solution to minimum wage issues is
supply and demand if but but again it's
it's the system is never going to change
this will always be the case even if
it's done through capitalism or if it's
done through government command
economies the only thing that you'll get
is ebbs and flows
so one of the things i think is good
about a minimum wage increase is that
imported goods that we get from slaves
will be easier to acquire for people
working minimum wage
americans don't want to admit the
reality of their slave-made goods but
that's the reality so if a slave is
going to work for one hour to make you
know 50 shirts in the united states if
we give you a minimum wage increase that
won't be a wage increase for the slave
who's getting paid garbage or not
getting paid at all americans love their
foreign products they absolutely do made
in china across the board
if we were to increase the wage of the
sweatshop worker
same as you you would not see you might
see a lag in goods that already exist
coming through and so that's one benefit
of raising minimum wages so if a shirt
is made and then the person gets paid to
make it and they go and buy food and
then 30 days later the shirt arrives the
cost of that shirt is still say five
bucks
however in the past week you got a
dollar raise and you made six bucks this
week so you can buy the five dollar
shirt and have a dollar left over it
feels good however
now that they've given a raise to the
other guy within a week's time the
shirt's now six dollars so raising the
minimum wage is a temporary it's a ponzi
scheme the whole the whole system is a
big ponzi scheme but you know there you
go it buys you about eight months the
people love those eight months of of
currency
raise because you can get 20 more stuff
well look what happened at the beginning
of the pandemic our government engaged
in the largest transfer of wealth that
has occurred in all of human history
they printed about 2.2 trillion about
450 billion of that went to the fed to
leverage out 4.5 trillion in loans and
the way the wealth is redistribute
redistributed in a very insidious way is
the people who get the money first in
loans before the inflation really hits
are the ones who benefit and that comes
off the back of everyone else who now
has more difficulty affording things and
who have lost the value of their savings
because that money was printed devaluing
the currency or because it was flooded
into the marketplace devaluing the
currency the people that get first
access to the money yes that's really
disturbing exactly yeah it's a
redistribution of wealth from people who
access the money first or two people who
access the money first from everybody
else but that was because they actually
added money into the system that didn't
exist prior to that point yeah so it
would be different if you're raising
minimum wage and a corporate a corporate
boss was told you have to raise the wage
to 15 an hour but you have to do it out
of the resources you currently have
you're not getting more from me i'm not
going to print money and give it to you
but it i mean it affects so for example
you have inflation in certain sectors
just depending on how the wealth is
redistributed
as opposed to new money being created so
for example when the federal government
started guaranteeing student loans
colleges started raising their prices
which was an inflation within that
particular field even though new money
wasn't actually created so you'd have to
actually stop greedy inflation because
there's really no more demand it's not a
supply or demand issue and you're
talking about things like college
education necessarily
yeah i know i hear you i mean i would
agree with you things that are not
tangible when you're looking at college
education there's certainly yeah i mean
it's it's greed but we also know based
on all the research according to the
national bureau for economic research i
should say colleges are going to respond
to those kinds of subsidies by raising
the prices i think what we have to do is
just shift the incentives and consider
the incentives before implementing any
kind of policy because
the idea behind guaranteeing student
loans was more people will be able to go
to college it was a very nice idea but
but they didn't actually think through
the incentives that was creating for the
colleges and it ended up making college
less accessible for everybody in the
long run that's why you have to do it as
a two-step process so not only do you
offer an affordable education to
somebody in a way by giving them some
sort of access to a loan or
or even just tuition free tuition but
you then would have to have the second
step being that you do the control on
the university itself yeah i think
there's an argument to be made i think
to look into a specific policy
prescription there but i think we just
you know
get rid of universities
you always say that right we need
education do you like the house you live
in because you need an architect to
build it do you like the roads you drive
on do you like the doctors you guys this
house wasn't built by an architect
either well somebody had to actually
then it's not structurally sound and is
it going to collapse on me
this house was actually built by a bunch
of local dudes
but either way some architecture over
time had
somebody had to check it to make sure
that it was structurally sound and that
me that was an educated person who
understood
architecture in order to ensure that the
beams are in the right spot that you
have support beams where they need to be
so of course it's true no i mean what
about a skyscraper so you just won't let
anybody just go and build a skyscraper
without an education and know how to do
it do you need a certification to build
a skyscraper
it sure helps i mean look like i'm not
going to go to just any random yahoo
architecture
for my doctors for example so
architecture is art and engineering is
the actual structure right so an
architect will like draw a pretty
picture of a building with like cool
like arches and the engineer has to
figure out how to distribute weight and
do things like that for this house
specifically this this is true story i
it's it was built
by a bunch of local guys who just knew
uh
basic carpentry and and construction and
so they all understood the basic weight
every beam of wood has like a you know
uh what
what's the right word um
how much weight it can withstand so they
have like two beams here two beams there
and they're like okay these beams can
hold this weight so we can build up to
this side because the total weight
pressed
it's not it's not
it's not coming from university they
learn these things so we've built stuff
on our own we're having skate ramps
built and it's just guys who know how to
put nails in wood and know the general
capacity of certain wood
they just they you learn these things
over time you can learn those things but
how do you control the quality of that
education that somebody learned so
somebody could come knocking on my door
like a snake oil salesman and be like
hey guess what kim i could build you a
house in your backyard i know how to do
it i learned all of it where did you
learn it online i watched youtube videos
okay fine but how show me your work
right well somebody would have to have
trusted him to start an apprenticeship
but here's the thing i mean so the
person gets a job as an apprentice when
they're young working for that's no
different than a university that's what
a university is apprenticeship just
online no no one pays you and you pay
the other but a lot of times you can't
find an apprentice that'll take you on
because it's a nepotist you know the
nepotism or it's who you know or they're
paid off by somebody it's essentially a
university i mean that's a university is
just but that's not an argument for the
for the for the for the situation at
hand that's just an argument for protect
maybe there's crime or maybe there's
social problems
if the issue is
you're going to tell someone to go spend
tens of thousand dollars go to
university so they can learn something
and be in a classroom versus someone can
get paid to work even if you're just
getting coffee to start for the first
month and actually watch something
happening in real time university is
detrimental
so well first of all i don't think you
should have to pay tens of thousands of
dollars for university so it should be
something that is well who pays for it
well i don't think
knowledge shouldn't be so expensive i
mean you certainly would want your
professors and the
to to be able to live and feed their
families and have a nice life so that
they're incentivized to become
professors
but it doesn't need to be
to the level where it's at where these
universities are getting these huge you
know they have these massive
uh accounts worth billions and billions
of dollars i mean it's just outrageous
well so you know you'd have to find that
so with this whole idea of going to a
society and just eliminating university
well i'm not actually calling for
eliminating universities you just did
that was me being hyperbolic for i
thought those failures say it every time
i talk i don't think you're really like
you don't like university i think people
shouldn't go to them but i think in
terms of like research at universities
and grants are fine for certain jobs
like um you want to be a doctor i
understand why we make people go to
school to be a doctor and get a
certification there but for the most
part universities should be like
at a side you know well so maybe they've
expanded and maybe you don't maybe you
don't agree with all of the all of the
uh topics that they teach i'll tell you
this
if someone tries to get a job from me
and they have
college on their resume it's a net
negative outright out of the gate but
that's just because you have bias but
that's just you
you absolutely yeah yeah quite literally
and it's because in my experience i have
already hired many people who have spent
too much time at institutionalized
learning facilities and have not enough
real world experience they can't
understand how to make things function
properly so for me personally i'm like
if you've spent this much of your life
in school you probably
you know i think that's a negative
however portfolio is the most important
thing you come to me and say i went to
college i'll say sure whatever show me
your portfolio you can't do that i'm not
interested
but my issue is you know i've spent a
lot of time around people who have
chosen to start working from a young age
worked side jobs throughout high school
and then decided to get into an industry
outside of high school and then a lot of
people who went to college and didn't
know what they're going to college for
but they were told to by their parents
and that's what everyone was told to do
racked up a bunch of debt and now have
no idea what they're doing their lives
that are miserable paying off debt
working crappy jobs
right so the debt part is the issue it's
not really the actual experience of
going to college because you can't
expect every 18 year old to know what
they want to do with their lives at the
time that they're 18. i disagree i think
that's a huge social problem we have i
knew what i wanted to do for the most
part but that was you so again it's you
know there's a lot of people that
they're still finding themselves and
they shouldn't be at 18 because you're
an adult at 18. and so for so this is
one of the problems we have as a country
when i was a little kid i was playing
music i was skateboarding i was
rollerblading and i was programming
websites and video games on a computer
and i was reading the news when i was
like 10 years old i'm on compuserve and
aol and i'm reading articles and i'm
doing it and somehow managed to here i
am you know not 36. a bunch of my
friends were doing literally nothing you
know they're my i was homeschooled from
the time i was born until i started
preschool until i started kindergarten a
bunch of my friends sat around doing
nothing but watching tv just mindless
nonsense by the time they're 18 they're
like i don't know what i'm doing and i
was like i've written several songs i've
recorded and published them i've made
several websites i've done a bunch of
odd jobs and then people are like go to
college i was like what for
i already i'm already working i'm
already getting experience and all this
stuff and i'm watching people go to
college being completely clueless the
problem is we as a society have been
telling our kids to do nothing and say
just go to school just go to school
we've put them in institutionalized
learning facilities that don't teach
them anything school sucks you know
every every kid thinks it every kid says
it so we're taking kids and saying for
the for 22 years of your life you're
going somewhere you hate now you're 22.
you're out of college i expect you to
have skills that's going to be valuable
to society and they don't it's not
surprising
but a lot of them do a lot of them do i
think that's a relative argument i think
if you took a kid who grew up and worked
on his dad's farm or in his dad's
smithing shop or smelting you know work
smelling or watched his dad weld and
then he grew up and went to high school
and learned basic math and stuff and
working at the family business you take
that person at 18 compared to an 18 year
old who did none of those things the 18
year old fresh out of high school who
worked for his dad's job is going to
tell you about accounting finance
banking he's going to explain to you
what time the workers come in he's going
to know about the labor laws and that
other kid's going to be like i have no
idea what any of that is and you expect
the kid who did nothing but go to an
institutionalized learning facility to
know what they want to do with their
life the kid who was welding when he was
13 is gonna be like i once made this
really cool structure with my dad
they're gonna have that memory they're
gonna have the experience at the very
least they're gonna have real world work
experience and connections in their
community i think school is one of the
biggest detriments to human civilization
i think that i understand parents can't
be there explaining math and history to
all these kids but now you take a look
at what's going on with like florida
don't say gay you take a look at what's
going on with teachers refusing to let
parents know what they're teaching their
kids and then teaching these kids a lot
of complete wacky activist nonsense i'm
like it's just gotten worse from the
get-go we used to be a civilization of
apprentices the kids would watch the
parents work i not not only was i
homeschooled but my mom opened a coffee
house and i got to watch how the
business worked so i'm in sixth grade
and i'm i'm earning money and so i've
got money i've got responsibility i
bought my own game boy and my own
pokemon red that was that was for me i
guess in this civilization i was lucky
to have all those things you were i wish
that my parents had a business i always
wished that growing up and that's what
we need to do
but the thing is is it you know i agree
with you that society definitely pushes
education way too hard and that they
devalue
the apprenticeship sort of track for
kids and i do agree that they absolutely
allow kids to just kind of go through
and not know what they're wanting to do
and just continue on that aimless path
but you know just even looking in you
sharing your experience my me sharing
mine anecdotally my dad on his side of
the family my grandfather was a farmer
he was the son of a farmer that
immigrated here from denmark then ran
the farm my grandfather hated the farm
he became a team through he was a
trucker he supported all seven kids
being a truck driver my grandmother was
a secretary at a newspaper
all seven of my dad's siblings of the
seven kids my dad was the only one who
went to college everybody else in my
family blew collar workers they all
worked in factories they were dry
cleaners they were landscapers they were
working to the bone every day
backbreaking work my dad went to college
got a computer programming degree was
able to then get a really good job
out of the seven kids we absolutely had
more money than the others there's no
doubt about that how old was your dad
like when was he born
47.
so my theory on this is that your dad
likely went to college because he liked
computers and he was passionate about
something see back then our society
didn't tell people college was mandatory
right so your dad you know so if you're
if you're in this age you know in the in
the 60s and 70s
people were able to get a high school
diploma and then support their family a
family of five just a high school
diploma was normal so why go to college
at all unless you really wanted to
because you were passionate about it so
i'd argue your dad made more money
because of his passion not because he
went to college well it because the job
he got commanded more money so he was
able to get a job of a higher wage that
put us into upper middle class versus my
family which was blue collar middle
class you know you know what i love
jimmy john's sandwiches is it difficult
to make sandwiches
no do you need a degree to learn how to
make a sandwich absolutely not but jimmy
john is a rich dude because he made a
lot of sandwiches right so
the college argument for wealth me to me
makes absolutely no sense you could you
could be the best dang chimney sweep in
the country and be a millionaire but
that's like one but that's a few so you
have an entire group of let's say
lawyers right as a whole on average they
make way more money than an entire group
of sandwich makers so you've got yes the
jimmy john who happens to be and i know
jimmy john actually who happens to
be we ordered jimmy john every day this
week because of my birthday week i love
jimmy john's also but i
yeah i used to live in champaign
illinois i did radio really at the time
yeah i've been through the area quite a
bit yeah we put them on the panini grill
and get them oh man oh really i've never
tried that oh that's good yeah i mean
they are good with them damn good
sandwiches right yes lawyers make more
than sandwich makers but my point on
average right no matter what job you
choose you can be rich if you're
passionate and driven also sandwich
makers are much more popular
that's true they're way more liked right
there's no doubt about that but you know
i look at my mom's side of the family
for example and they're all vietnamese
immigrants and what do you think
vietnamese immigrants do when they come
here to america i'll give you one guess
nobody wants to be there
nobody wants to i want to say something
but i'm not going to say it on tv you
said dry nail salons right so they do
nail salons so everybody in my family on
my mom's side and they work and they
scrub feet literally for a living
it is it's very hard work and they do it
so that they would put my generation
through college and what do they tell
all of us kids they say you're going to
go to college and you're going to be
engineer you're going to be doctor
you're going to be a lawyer right and
that's it and that was the only choices
we had we had like three choices and
that's all you could be and it was they
were scrubbing feet in order to put us
into college in order to get those jobs
because on average now my generation
which is you know now we're in our 30s
and 40s we on average make more money
than my mom's generation now that being
said my aunt
is a very wealthy nail salon owner who
owns a ton of nail salons in the beverly
hills area so she owned five nails she
does all the celebrity nails she's been
the big hot shot nail salon owner in
beverly hills since 1988 makes the most
money out of everybody there's no doubt
about that but collectively as a whole
my generation makes more money than my
mom's generation
on average so there was the one that got
lucky but she has to support the rest
my generation none of us have to support
each other because we all make enough
money to support ourselves i mean why i
don't think it's luck at all you know
one one it was hard work for sure but it
was also luck because a lot of other
people work very very hard and i don't
want to discount the fact that somebody
works very very hard but just never got
the break in life to make a bunch of
money i think it's the break i think
it's you know the the saying is chance
favors the prepared
some people are prepared to make
sacrifices or take chances and others
aren't but sometimes your chance and and
the success like you were born here in
america so you had the opportunity to
have a lot of success in america but if
you were an immigrant coming in from
like el salvador and you've got to
literally walk your rear end all the way
across a continent to get yourself into
america that was a lot of hard work and
then you get here and maybe you're only
living in a two-bedroom apartment but to
you that's rich thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you